well well reject nation looks like we
got
ourselves a potential spider-man 3
no way home plot leak this is coming
from
our buddy warren over at cosmic wonder
who's been killing it lately i love
whenever we covered a cosmic wonder
video because there's always someone in
the comments
who's like gosh all you do is cover
cosmic wonder and cover someone else
jesus even though it's been many weeks
there's going to be someone
what are you guys talking about yeah
come on if anything it's like mostly tv
now
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder today
we have a spider-man
no way home plot leak and honestly this
does sound pretty dang interesting
if the story ends up being somewhat like
this it's going to be a heck of a movie
and yes of course this does involve the
spider verse
now of course with all plot lakes it's
hard to tell if this is legitimate or
not
some plot leaks end up being true and a
lot of them end up not being true
this was posted anonymously online to
several pages like reddit and
4chan by somebody who was fortunate to
have seen the storyboard for spider-man
no way home so like with all leaks take
this with a grain of salt
but like i said it does sound very very
exciting so let's get into it but first
i am giving away a captain america
falcon and the winter soldier shield the
giveaway ends at the end of this month
just subscribe to me and my other
channel cosmic culture
i'll put the link in the description
down below that's how you enter so let's
get started
one second texting warren hey dude i
have a question
can i get that captain america shield
if i follow the rules
yeah is this a fair competition it opens
with spider-man being chased through a
broken
new york by some type of human
thunderstorm the electricity takes a
human shape
and turns out to be jamie foxx he can
fly right away
stating that he knows who he is and then
he takes off his mask and it is
in fact toby mcguire electro is about to
kill spider-man but right before he does
the reality around them fractures and
the marvel opening credits begin
we then pick up right where we left off
and spider-man fire from home
tom holland's peter parker has just seen
the broadcast and is rushing home
desperately contacting aunt may and
happy he reaches his
home and tells aunt may they have to
hide they will become targets
but it's too late as the apartment
complex is attacked by michael mando's
scorpion
and his men in the fight
scorpion falls down breaking his back
and aunt may and peter
escape they seek rev god scorpions can't
catch a break
in dr strange strange is busy analyzing
several fractures to their reality which
started after the blip but have been
increasing
peter wants a spell to reverse the
uncovering of his identity
asking doctor strange what he can do but
doctor strange can do no spell
but in return he offers the asylum to
mae for her to hide and tells tom that
he should solve this like most people
in court then
[Laughter]
it was pretty funny used looking at
jamie foxx's electro
the old avengers tower now belongs to
oscorp and they are in fact
experimenting with fragments of both the
tesseract
pym particles and traces of the ether
found in london
phineas mason is working on this new
technology for an
unseen norman osborne and this leak
describes him as more of an elon musk
type of guy
less overtly evil and more charismatic
heck maybe elon musk is playing the
character himself i'm sure he'd love to
do that
multiple fractures are reported
peter parker stands trial at court and
is unsuccessfully
defended by matt murdock aka daredevil
that's how you bring back matt murdock
matt murdock is going to be in
spider-man no way home however
daredevil is not only going to be matt
murdock defending peter parker
but it does go on to say due to the
reality ripples
peter has to rush out of court and goes
to a large anomaly near the docks
when he gets there doctor strange is
trying to contain the anomaly but dr
strange is pulled into the anomaly and
peter is unable to save him
peter then goes and contacts shield he
thought that mysterio lied about the
other dimensions
but they believe mysterio's scheme is a
part of something much bigger
he had a benefactor scorpion is brought
to michael keaton who of course is
playing adrian
tombs aka vulture and he runs a large
repair shop
vulture owes scorpion for their time
shared in prison
and they offer up a lot of cash to take
care of scorpion
with the help of the tinkerer they use
one of the old iron man 2 suits that
they have collected to create an
exoskeleton for scorpion with a backed
base cannon
and this would obviously make him look
more like squirrel what
stock tank is a tinkerer too
brought into ozcorp and he's greeted by
norman osborne
this norman osborne seems relatively
nice with the disbanding of the avengers
norman wants to create his own
privatized team of superheroes
as told by his advisor he's been getting
messages from another reality by none
other than willem dafoe's
norman osborne and we have had some
reports from some media outlets that
willem dafoe could be reprising his role
as norman osborne in spider-man
i was confirmed and this norman osborne
is giving hints on how to create a
quantum portal to connect
both realities this is one of the few
surviving
realities just to see the realities are
desperate to go to this reality
the villains in this movie all come from
realities that have been mostly
destroyed
this norman osborne believes himself to
be some kind of tony stark and is
building his own group of superheroes
shelters are built for the heavens
that's pretty cool
you were introduced to the grc in the
falcon and the winter soldier
grc stands for the global repatriation
council and right now in the falcon and
the winter soldier we're kind of on the
fence on whether or not they're truly
good or not
we're not sure if they have ulterior
motives yet debates are held about this
reality taking in refugees from other
realities
missing people duplicates and the like
are taken care of
among them is ben parker as one of the
few living relatives aunt may is
contacted and even peter learns of his
existence
both aunt may and peter go to see him
ben
is happy to see both of them as in his
reality they both had died
admittingly this would be a pretty cool
twist granted it wouldn't really be the
same it's not the same ben parker he
wouldn't have experienced the same thing
that they all went through together it
sure
is reality but it still would be pretty
cool to see learning from
shield that the anomaly is coming from
the oldest that was so long
this is like really detailed osborne
with the intention of shutting the
machine down
spider-man is still a wanted criminal
and norman tells him of a persistent
chance he tells him the idea that some
things are simply
inevitable as if reality converges to
certain events
like how most realities have a
spider-man he thought
labeling this spider-man criminal would
be enough
but he flushes the spider-man down the
drain into an alternate reality
r tom holland peter parker wakes up in a
ravaged earth
not destroyed by thanos but by ego
star-lord's father
has moved underground it sounds like
this is fan fiction
yeah this is not real every new step is
a character
i want to hear the rest of this but i'm
going to pause this right now to say
like i don't think this is real like
this you got the ego yeah
it sounds like an insane hyper fan
fiction and maybe some of this stuff
will come true
at the moment though as i'm listening to
this even the fact that it starts off
where you see toby maguire at the very
beginning
that sounds a little too far-fetched for
me and i can start off with electro and
toby mcguire at the very top
i mean like it would be a cool stinger
surprise tease thing but at the same
time it also seems like they wouldn't
want to reveal that at the very
beginning of the movie
yeah and i'll bite my words you know
sounds awesome it sounds awesome yeah
we're hearing all kinds of crazy casting
is supposed to go on in this movie
at the same time though it sounds um
like oh
what like way too much at a certain
point you're talking about the tinker
and getting scorpion in there and him
getting the suit and you're building up
the suit and you've got norman osborne
leading the child like there's just so
much happening here it's a little too
much
well where's doc ock humanity has moved
underground where dr octavius is taking
care of survivors
our peter parker is able to lead them
into another fracture of reality
they pass multiple different realities
and come across two
other spider-man our peter parker learns
about the feeling of seeking refuge and
has to find his way back home
following the trail that doctor strange
has left behind
back in the main mcu reality norman
osborne completes the quantum tuttle
bridging his reality to willem dafoe's
reality wollum defeats norman osborne
enters and then he promptly kills the
other norman osborne
willem dafoe wants to enjoy this reality
and he lavishes in its luxury
when traveling through different
realities our peter parker eventually
does find doctor strange and he is able
to take them back to the main reality
the leak describes it as when they get
back to the reality it's a little like
back to the future too
things have been taken over by oscorp as
time has passed for several months
it has become highly militarized and
willem defoe's norman osborne has
several protectors including
scorpion with his upgraded suit there's
the final battle which takes place over
several ravaged versions of new york
including one with dark elves
eventually
which will condemn all of the other
earths to their fate the reality
displaced people refract and go back to
their own sounds more like a multiverse
of madness if you ask me
and peter parker says goodbye to the
other spider-man
they tell him that he's lucky and he
needs to take good care of his world
in the ending sequence the dead body of
our norman osborne is revived by dr
connor tinging his skin with a green hue
dr connor obviously being the lizard
and that's it for this plot league
and unfortunately there's no real way to
tell if this is legitimate or not
i think a movie like this would actually
be pretty cool to see
and although i doubt 100 of this will
happen i think some type of variation of
this would be
really really cool but let me see the
inspired fan fiction
would you like to see spider-man no way
home play out like the supposed plot
lake
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching
i mean i think it would be cool there's
a lot of elements to this
that i really like we could talk about
the details of everything
here for sure and like review this as if
it was a real movie
scorpion i love all the inclusions of
bringing back michael mando the
idea of like how he gets the suit
upgraded from the iron man 2
suit an older version like keeping that
all tied and connected yeah
introducing the tinkerer and then having
that lead with
norman osborne and then also kind of
setting up your centers
yeah it all sounds fun but at the same
time this sounds
way more disjointed and more unfocused
than amazing spider-man 2 or spider-man
3-d
yes it really did broach after a while
on and then storytelling yeah
this guy and then this guy and yeah like
the biggest
worry for me about this upcoming
spider-man movie is the fact that
all spider-man franchises up until this
point have succumbed to this bloat
for their you know third or perhaps even
second installment they're
really gonna have to temper and balance
how they control
all these crazy elements and so while i
imagine any recap
of this storyline will sound a little
bit like and then
like it is gonna have to have a bit more
finesse than at least this suggested to
me because once you start getting like
oh there's ego and here are some elves
and stuff
those things could just be like small
little extra i think it has to like
build to a crazy finale yeah like this
sounds like
crazy right away yeah yeah yeah
especially with that toby tease at the
beginning toby and
election at the beginning it's like a
cool fan fiction
and building up to this within like
reading comic books or graphic novels
totally works i don't see how you can
just come back with spider-man 3
spider-man no way home
and just do all this yeah it's a little
much the first half i was like
okay is scorpion in the main villain
okay is it tinker okay is it norman
osborne as it just kept progressing i'm
like this
this is a graphic novel this wouldn't
translate super well to a movie
at least from hearing it right up front
do i think andrew garfield and toby
mcguire are in here
yes because i thought already said plot
league i thought it'd be like a little
thing i didn't think it would be
oh you're telling me all three acts
right now yeah
it was didn't he say like this was
somebody caught a glimpse of the
storyboards i'm like oh this is
more than a glimpse you like studied
these yeah you're able to reiterate yeah
the entire movie there are parts of it
that sound really cool
it's definitely gonna have to build and
it all rides on tone especially for
something like this
tone and emotional experience that will
have to distract you from like
science mumbo jargon yeah details and
then like wait how does this work again
yeah just as crazy as this movie wants
to be i think there is an onus on it to
be just as sort of dramatically punchy
too because you
have to pin it with something that we
truly care about to make the fun all
worthwhile
i'm like what's the real plot here i
thought he was on the run oh he's not on
the run he just he's going to court
and then they just let him leave court
early like what yeah halfway through i
was like damn
does peter really matter to this story
it seems like we're just hopping around
so many places sounds like a dream is
happening
it does which i'm down for like an
atonal sort of weird abstract spider-man
but we're just not there yet okay here's
how it sounded
all the pieces that are here most of
them are going to be in the movie the
way
it sounds like how they would build it
and introduce
each piece i'm not a big fan of from
hearing this so no i don't i don't think
it's going to play out i think this is
this
is
way too calm it was like a four-hour
film with jesus
man after the snyder cut all right guys
well do you like this plot leak
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
thank you warren for unveiling this i'm
sure there's gonna be way more to come
last but not least
justin justin you're in the movie now
you're one of our newest
patrons and i want an origin story for
you i want to know all about you how you
got to be
who you are what your powers are what
the struggles are between balancing
regular life
as you justin the man
the myth but also then you know fighting
crime and dealing with multiversal
madness that's the way i want to get to
know you so don't bother writing us a
message or anything
i just want a film origin story with as
many
crazy plot turns and extra characters as
possible the less sense it makes in fact
the better because then we can just
continue going to that well for these
shout outs and just saying like oh hey
oh justin you've flying through the
universe with elves and stuff and then
oh damn oh look he's doing a rap battle
cause why not
hey now it's a tender romantic comedy
what hasn't justin done
you got a great life i'm jealous of you
justin thanks for being here i love you
you would be great in a writer's room i
need to be in a writing team
yeah let me just see what comes out of
my brain